when you see the word applications what
that means is okay we want to see how
this idea relates to something that we
find in the real world okay and the most
important thing the trigonometry is when
you don't want it if you want to know
where stuff is
that's position okay so first we're
going to focus on angles for position
two different kinds both of which you've
met before but maybe you haven't heard
of them together okay the first thing is
when you go something like this this is
pivot point so this is where we are okay
and we're looking at something like say
a light bulb
okay so a flagpole maybe you're looking
at the top it's a vertical angle away
from right so around this diagram what I
want you to include first is a wide on
the ground to the base of the platform
what on the ground to the basement level
now when you can kind of imagine the
angle that you're measuring I could draw
it flat but this is something that
exists in 3d space the space that we
live in so I'm kind of looking at this
the fancy written it's an isometric
diagram I'm looking at it from a
perspective okay what I want you to
imagine is if you were to draw the
triangle the velocity it's on a big flat
piece of paper like this can you imagine
the piece of paper can you imagine it
stretching all the way between you and
the flagpole and now what you'd imagine
okay where is the angle as I look to the
taller or the flagpole let's join up
that line okay so what I'm doing is
looking at its side on now even though
it doesn't look like it because of the
perspective there is a right angle which
is hot mitral an English but there's a
right angle in this triangle that I've
just drawn where is it
yeah very good that's it precisely right
between the flag and the more so what
I'm going to do
is I'm gonna indicate that with the
right angle sign doesn't look like one
looks like it's obtuse but that's
because of perspective okay now what
we're doing is we're looking up at that
we're looking oh so I'm gonna measure
this angle I'm just gonna call it alpha
you'll see what I call it alpha a minute
rather than its opinion they don't
I want another angle in this diagram in
a bit so what I'm looking at is on a
vertical plane this piece of paper is
standing up on its edge so this is about
vertical position okay now because we're
looking up at it like you're literally
bracing your eyes does anyone remember
this is called an angle of elevation
fantastic because an elevator what it
does is it takes things up so this is an
angle of elevation if on the other hand
we were somewhere high I wouldn't doubt
something we call that an angel long
depression so for instance maybe there's
like an ant or a bird on the top of that
flagpole and it's looking at us waving
at angle of depression B when I draw it
how red okay it's good enough to be like
from this point of view rather down here
but here's a really important thing when
I'm measuring from the ground and I
measure up if I'm doing elevation if I'm
doing depression I'm gonna measure from
again from a flat line and then down
okay so in fact there's a line missing
here that I need I'm gonna add it in now
it's this line here okay so if I was
that bird up there and now I'm looking
down that in there is the angle of
depression
it's the same size can anyone tell me
why it's the same size hmm okay so I
heard a few different words right the
most particular that's helpful is
alternate right so these two angles are
alternate but they're not just alternate
they're alternating between these two
lines and these two lines are just
random lines they're related does anyone
know how these lines are related yeah
very good actually all heading in the
same direction the parallel lines so
what I'm gonna do just really small I'm
gonna write this this is the angle of
depression and this one over here is the
angel of animation the size of the
angles is the same but where they are is
very different so that's all about when
you're looking up and down okay
angles of elevation of us angles of
depression and because you see a right
angle here you also see a right angle
yeah all of your trig stuff is going to
be useful in this sinner okay so that's
vertical position what's the other kind
of position that might be relevant for
us to live in 3d space horizontal okay
so remember I said we're drawing this
diagram with perspective so what I'm
gonna do now is just like there's a
giant vertical piece of paper I'm gonna
lady on a giant horizontal piece of
paper so it's kind of like here we go
I'm laying out I'm laying out some
carpet okay so this is flat this is all
on the ground this is standing on an
edge this is up in
yeah let's put something here let's put
a person shall we so if I put a person
over here now if I measure an angle for
the position of that person something
like say this straw a line all the way
over there if you want to describe
something to position the angles
difference between you and this person
over here okay what are they call that
we don't call them angles of elevation
or depression that's all about up and
down what might we use sideways ish is a
very nice technical mathematical term
let me give you a clue we're talking
about position like which way we face
you all tiny people used to hold
something that started with a see if
they can point around they'll use a
compass right so a compass bearing a
compass bearing is one way to talk about
what's your angle to that person okay so
just for the sake of argument let's
suppose that this direction of over here
is north
okay so again that red line is still on
the ground we want to put an angle in to
work out which way this person is facing
do I put it okay sure so I'm gonna put
in this angle over here this is the
reason why I called this alpha let's
call this guy B naught okay
or beta they're both a plane it just
looks like a beam in the tail
so this guy down here I'm measuring from
North I could use a compass to sort of
point there maybe it's sort of northeast
I guess
there's another way to talk about when
you've got things on the ground
horizontal angles they're not compass
bearings they are another kind of
bearing see what they go so compass
bearings or true bearings are both for
talking about horizontal position okay
when you describe something in terms of
compass bearing can someone give me an
example of a compass bearing I actually
have one already written on the board
north northeast northwest southeast
Southwest whatever okay so we have an
8.0 compass right so never eat soggy
weet-bix and of course all the
in-between words what are the imagery
ones
okay we've got North East we've got I
guess you could go in twice board up
what would come next would be I guess
sound these then you're gonna get
Southwest so if you want you can draw
your self a little compass here and you
can label it accordingly
but as you can imagine this is a very
blunt instrument if someone is standing
in between one of these end points it
becomes a bit cumbersome to say well
they're kinda there's sort of not really
okay and that's which few things come in
can someone give me the example of how I
might write a true bearing sure so for
103 degrees to make sure we know it's
true we had one more thing which is the
let it's here usually occasionally
you'll see it without the tea but you
want to be as ambiguous as possible as
clear as possible and that means
everyone knows what you're talking about
okay what's the advantage of doing this
over this it's like yeah precision okay
not only if they saw might begin between
but here you could say are exactly 46
degrees and if you can measure that
across that'll be me angry again okay
one lesbians worth mentioning these
things because they are written in
degrees right what's them then why just
a nun bar that you can think of that you
could put in here especially for 360
right 360 is the same as going all the
way around and coming back to north so
it's not normal to say 360 we'd normally
just say zero that's what you started
right so what would be the next things
number 359 that's the biggest one okay
so as a result all of these are three
digits long basically like 103 284 it's
never going to get bigger than 359 okay
so much side of these are often called
three-digit bearings okay in fact people
like this convention so much that even
if the number isn't three digits long
like this doesn't look like it's three
digits long does it what angle would you
call that just give me an estimate 25
people would say that's zero for five
degrees T and that's what they mean by
four
well I mean it's kind of for the sake of
consistency and so we all know exactly
what you're talking about which is a big
deal I'm gonna make sure they
communicate clearly ok very good
position that's [ __ ] down horizontal
position that's all of these bearings
where do you measure true from which
stop you stop you always start from zero
but when zero like it's not okay which
is one I put North in and you always go
clockwise does anyone know why we go
clockwise because that's the way Cox
code in English in English when we write
words and numbers we read the script
form left to right of course not every
script in the world is like that Hebrew
Japanese Chinese one of those are
actually right to left
yeah but in English in English we start
pretty normal and then we go clockwise
in fact that's probably worth drawing
you know how you put your compass rose
over here dropping me something down
here for true bearings as well you
always start from North and then you go
around and you measure clockwise